التطور التكنولوجي وثوره المعلومات الى ان
يكون العالم قريه واحده امرا طبعا له
ايجابيات كثيره لكن السلبيات موجوده ايضا
عمليه النص والاحتيال الالكتروني
الجريمه الالكترونيه كانت ذات يوم موضوعا
رائعا لاحدث الافلام في التسعينيات كان
الامر خياليا الان مات واقعا في كل العالم
وفي العالم العربي تنتشر هذه الظاهره
وبقوه
137 الف مواطنا عربي يقومون يوميا بزياره
مواقع الاحتيال المالي هذا الامر اتضح
بشكل جلي في مصر خلال الايام الماضيه
واحده من اكبر عمليات النصب والاحتيال في
تاريخ مصر بالسنوات الاخيره
المجتمع المصري اصلا من بعد عام 2011 وهو
يشهد تزايدا في جرائم النصب والاحتيال
احدى الدراسات التي اجريت في الفتره من
2011 الى 2018 اظهرت تعرض
51.7% من النسبه الاجماليه لعينه الدراسه
الى جرائم مرتبطه بالاموال والائتمان
السنين تمر وتزداد معها طرق الاحتيال
والنصب بفعل التطور التكنولوجي بالطبع
اخرها هذه العمليات كان ما حدث بدايه
الشهر الجاري منصه استثمار الكترونيه
حديثه تدعى هوج بول للاستثمار والارباح
تصنف نفسها على انها متخصصه في تعدين
البيتكوين وتقديم خدمات التعدين السحابي
جمعت المنصه من ست الى سبعه مليارات جنيه
مصري من نحو 600 الف مشترك الذين سعوا
للكسب السريع رغم ان الاستثمار في العملات
الرقميه اصلا غير مشروع وف قا للقانون
المصري والنتيجه الشركه محتاله سرقت
الاموال نعم قبضت السلطات المصريه على
مسؤولين في الشركه لكن هل يعود ذلك بفائده
على من تم الاحتيال عليهم الاجابه محزنه
لا
فضلت بقى اتابع نظامهم شغالين ايه
وبيعملوا ايه والكلام دوت
لقيتهم ان هم موثقين
قال لك احنا موثقين تبع الحكومه المصريه
وعاملين عقد مع شركه فودافون وده اللي
خلانا ان احنا نبقى واثقين يعني دخل لنا
ان في نسبه ثقه
ان احنا نخش نشترك في الكلام دوت اه دخلت
ناس زمايلي دخلت فيها انا زمايلي